du point de vue du cerveau et je du
point de vue cerveau il n'ya pas
d'addiction à la pornographie ça ne
fonctionne pas comme d'autres types
d'addictions il peut y avoir une
utilisation excessive et de l'exposition
à la pornographie mais il n'y a pas de
transformation fondamentalement des
récepteurs dans le cerveau ou des
neurotransmetteurs dans le cerveau qui
ferait que tout d'un coup les
adolescents ne serait plus en mesure de
ne plus regarder de pornographie et
c'est un peu ce qu'on a entendu on voit
qu'il peut y avoir des phases où on
regarde beaucoup de pornographie et puis
des moments on en regarde - mais cette
on peut pas la qualifier d'une addiction
du même type que d'autres addictions
qu'on peut avoir par exemple à la
nicotine ou autres de la même manière il
n'ya pas d'addiction aux écrans ça
n'existe pas il peut y avoir une
utilisation excessive des écrans
mésusage des écrans il n'ya pas
d'addiction aux jeux vidéo
il ya un gaming disorders mais c'est
différent en tout cas quand on regarde
d'un point de vue neurobiologiques il
n'y a pas de transformation des
neurotransmetteurs de la fonctionnement
du cerveau du fait de l'utilisation des
écrans ou l'exposition à la pornographie
c'est que c'est une problématique mais
on peut pas tout en tout cas la
dimensionnalité dimensionnalité sur une
problématique d'addiction
[Musique]